we we also work the census but this is
these are our own views this work was
largely independent of our Census work
but inspired by some of our efforts so
that I want to focus on a class of
problems that I'm going to call
assignment problems which involve a
disjoint set of assignee populations and
in this talk we're they're basically
always going to be groups of people that
live in geographic regions and these
problems have to do with assigning like
benefits or privileges to these groups
of people that depend the decision to
grant those benefits and privileges
depends on statistics about those groups
okay so in the absence of privacy or
noise or anything we have a bunch of
disjoint groups we can compute some
statistics on them and then we run some
kind of assignment method to generate
outcomes one for each group a simple
example of an assignment method might be
you know a boolean outcome that you know
happens for an assignee population if
some property of that population is
greater than a threshold and doesn't
happen otherwise another example might
be proportional allocation where we have
an entitlement of money and we're going
to distribute it in proportion to some
qualifying population in each each
region ok so there's lots of really
important problems that fit this this
this format federal funds allocation the
assignee populations are you know states
or counties or school districts and
funds may be allocated to population
counts me not not in surely the whole
the total population but population of
some segment of the group congressional
apportionment of course is a really
important problem where states are
granted seats in the House of
Representatives and it's determined by
resident counts I'm going to talk about
an example later in some detail that is
fed federal funds allocation and I'm
going to talk about minority language
voting rights benefits which are granted
so so certain
voting jurisdictions are covered or not
covered and it's determined by a certain
set of statistics on the population and
their literacy and and how many people
speak foreign languages so and there's
other other examples that so now when
we're gonna move into like how to do
these assignment problems privately we
have to cope with the risk of mistakes
being made and so the mistakes here are
you know serious consequences in some
cases federal funds can be Mis allocated
seats in the house can be misallocated
than we have unfair representation
minority language voters can be
disenfranchised if they don't get the
benefit of voting materials published in
their language and so on so we expect
that we have to deal with some of these
consequences and we can think about it's
a natural social goal to try to minimize
in aggregate how much money is miss
allocated due to errors in the data that
we publish so we'll get to that and and
and part in the big the big point of
this talk is to think not just about
overall error and miss allocation and
these problems but also disparities and
whether different groups are treated
differently as a byproduct of privacy
mechanisms that's where I'm headed but
but before I get there I want to talk
about some different settings for how we
might do private assignments so this is
like the setting I showed you on the
first slide this is like non private
assignment the most natural approach and
and one that's close to what the census
does is that a publication with sort of
standard assignment what I mean by that
is that these assignee populations will
compute privately sums that the
supporting statistics about them so
we'll get noisy statistics out we then
just run the assignment mechanism kind
of as if they're true these statistics
are true and we get noisy outcomes
different slightly different approach
would be sort of data publication so we
release the the privately computed
statistics but we could change the
assignment function because now there's
noise and we should maybe do something a
little bit smarter we still get noisy
assignments out
out comes out and then of course we
could forgo publication completely and
do direct kind of differentially private
assignment and just go from compute you
know the noisy outcomes you know
directly might be able to do better in
this setting a little bit better but
there are some issues and so this talk
is really gonna focus on this first
setting which is the simplest and and
the reason for that is that you know
this is sort of preliminary work we're
just starting to think about and we
haven't gotten to the other settings yet
but also there's some significant
challenges to moving here okay first of
all you have to change the assignment
function and if you want to do that
intelligently you need to know something
about the noise and that information is
not always available second of all these
assignment functions are often encoded
in law or regulation it's not clear at
least to me that they can always be
changed and I think the biggest problem
with this approach is really that
there's no transparency so I mean a lot
of these critical problems rely on
people being able to check the outcomes
to some extent and trust them and I'm
not sure we have that if we go with pure
private assignment okay so now issues
with data quality are not a new thing
for the Census and errors and these
types of assignment problems have been
carefully considered but I want to point
out that you know even though for
example census tables that are based on
surveys include estimates of sampling
error those estimates and other
estimates of error that come with Census
publish data generally do not reflect
the impact of disclosure limitation okay
so we can't take that into account
easily if in in these assignment
problems what the census will do for
really important assignment problems is
is take special efforts to make sure
that assignment happens accurately for
redistricting an apportionment there are
some supporting statistics that will not
undergo disclosure limitation at all for
voting rights determinations there are
special variance reduction methods to
deal with the fact that the counts are
really small and
sampling error can be high okay so but
in general the published tables are
treated as true for assignment problems
and there's some assignment critical
assignment problems that the census is
sort of like very closely involved in
but there's also for sure
lots of assignment problems that are
carried out using census data that
senses that the Census Bureau knows
nothing about because the statistics are
published and used all over the place
okay so we have error we have these
important problems and we have privacy
mechanisms and we're moving towards
differential differentially private
mechanisms and so we've seen this graph
or versions of this graph a few times
this week
this is a paper that's a really nice
paper by John and Ian that that
motivated you know our our further
thinking about this problem and I'll
just remind people who might not have
seen that this is the sort of best
favored outcome where accuracy is
maximized and privacy loss is is
minimized and that this dark line is the
production frontier of sort of non
dominated solutions and that if you have
a if you know how you want to exchange
privacy loss and accuracy then you can
pick an optimal point so I want to so I
want to point out that in in their paper
and in a lot of mechanisms the accuracy
measure here is an aggregate error total
error and that corresponds to a
utilitarian social welfare in which
what's good about accuracy is sort of
like the sum of all the accuracy that
everybody gets and that's a different
social welfare function than others that
would think carefully about for example
how the worst person is doing and
whether some people are disadvantaged
relative to others so that's what I want
to talk about is accuracy disparity even
if we fix the privacy lost budget that's
acceptable and we pick the best
available mechanism from the plot we had
on the previous slide do assignee
populations bear the burden of
inaccuracy
equally or fairly so we might find that
you know if we were classifying our
counties in Texas that some almost
always get classified correctly but
others are really disadvantaged by the
fact that they they are very rarely
classified correctly so I want to show
you a different plot which is a sort of
a different social choice that we that I
think we have to make which is about
overall aggregate accuracy versus
disparities across the groups that are
that are receiving outcomes and this is
maximum accuracy so presumably on the
previous slide
you know first for whatever fixed
epsilon this is I mean it's sort of like
another dimension but I picked an
epsilon here so I have on this plot the
best mechanism the most accurate maximum
mechanism for that accuracy level but
here what I'm saying is that you know I
could pick that but at maximize accuracy
but I'm going to show you some examples
where that means that I will also create
disparities and that if I want to reduce
the disparities I will have to sacrifice
some overall accuracy this is not this
is not like a real graph it's like Oh
lots of situations where the
relationship is more positively
correlated how I'm gonna give you I'm
gonna give you a few different scenarios
specific scenarios where this phenomenon
arises from common mechanisms yeah some
of this I think probably comes down to
how you define accuracy disparity but if
you imagine going to the very bottom of
this line where you say we have zero
accuracy we're just going to make a
constant decision right you know what is
the Akrotiri in that case yeah well okay
yeah yeah no I think yeah I mean I think
in that case I mean this is I think this
is limited to a specific mechanism for a
specific epsilon in the plots that I'm
gonna make and I think I understand
where you're going with that question I
think but there there should be some you
should somehow get back to there fair
and no disparity if things get really
bad but yeah okay so in the remainder of
the talk I want to try to give you
specific examples like I said of where
these disparities can arise and then
those will be sort of like just sort of
like simple applications of existing
mechanisms and I think it won't answer
the question of whether these problems
are real in practice and so then we're
going to do some case studies and try to
see what the impacts look like for like
reasonable Epsilon's okay so what are
the things that can arise in mechanisms
different groups that are assignee
populations can have unequal error rates
in the counts that are estimated from
them right that just means that you know
like even if they're unbiased they can
have different variants and so one of
the aspects here is that these
assignment problems are not rerun very
frequently it's not that it's not that
we do apportionment you know every hour
and so that the random repeated random
trials things sort of like even out we
do these assignments often like annually
or every five years and so if you get a
bad coin flip you let you have to live
with it okay so unequal error rates
matter and bias and estimated counts and
also unequal outcome so these these are
these are like properties that we
observed about the error coming out of
the mechanism but you can also kind of
measure things at the in the outcome
space and see whether and that's a
little bit different and I'm we don't
really I don't think we're sure exactly
what we're to measure these effects and
what the right metrics are but I'm going
to show you where you know what creates
these effects and so post-processing can
create bias that adaptive algorithms
lead to leads Tobias
I'll show you examples where which are
very common where we optimize total
error on a work
and we get unequal error rates across
the population and then I'll show you an
example of like a threshold condition
and how in the outcome space even if you
have very sort of like fair air
distribution you get weird effects yes I
believe they all apply to a sample based
survey use the same way of comparisons
so you mean if we can if we can claim
that our mechanisms produce effects that
are sort of smaller than those effects
we'd be in good shape or I mean that
post-processing deliberately uses bias
and the language determinations in order
to control mean squared error
adaptive algorithms in that context are
ones that examine the space of actual
districts and actual languages to
attempt to minimize the discrepancies
between the the various ways that the
parameters of the post-processing can be
tuned
I really okay but focused on the privacy
mechanisms but the Census Bureau has to
use sample based surveys to do this just
okay takes the block tabulations from
that makes housing subsidy
determinations on them and then
complains the next year over the next
five year one because of sampling
variability has these things really all
over the place okay so I thank you for
pointing that out so these problems
exist independent of our privacy
mechanisms I think the point of this
work is to try to understand how are we
creating new effects in our privacy
mechanisms and I guess eventually we
have to understand how they come compose
with sampling based effects actually I'm
going slightly more general than that
you're trying to address a class of
problems that already exist in the use
of statistical data for making
especially zero-sum allocation problems
where there are both winners and losers
because it's a big spot okay
possibly not focusing so much on the
fact that your privacy preserving
algorithms that generated these outcomes
but focusing on
generic features of data processing that
then have to use noisy measures to make
zero-sum allocations is a more general
problem to talk about privacy mechanisms
okay have a selfish reason for doing
this singling out the privacy mechanisms
makes them look like they're about the
culprit here when really many of the
things that we needed induced noise and
data should be treated as the reasons
why the data are imperfect measures on
the thing you're trying to do
allocations the poverty measures which
have very limited disclosure economists
have been subjected to this kind of
scrutiny for decades some of these are
actually less you can reduce some of
them right and so I think germ is very
relevant here that this is the question
is sort of where do you ever find make
would you even reduce the problem that's
they already and that's okay I think
another key thing coming out of this is
there's a lot of work
already done there's languages people
use to talk about this and to the extent
that this can fit into that same
framework of language I think it buys us
a lot in terms of as John points out
saying that you know that this isn't a
new problem it's not a problem we've
introduced it's ok sorry well let me let
me try to go on I mean I certainly need
to learn more about that language and
that that history of work because it's
not my area but I understand what I
understand is privacy algorithms and I
want to understand where they create
these effects and how they compare
because I wanted needs to be generally
aware that these engineering problems
they do some statistical data for public
decision-making even allocation okay all
right oh my god okay so I'm gonna walk
through some mechanisms basic mechanism
we're gonna start with the basic things
here some true data it's a histogram
imagine that each bucket here is an is
one of these populations and that we're
reporting a count about that population
in order to make a decision okay if I
apply the Laplace mechanism then what
I'm showing you here is literally over
many trials this is a little box plot
with which which describes the
distribution of noise that each
population is going to experience and so
you see that it's it's like unbiased
noise and it's got equal sort of
variance this isn't exactly plotting
variance but it's got a you know equal
variances as we expect for the Laplace
mechanism what people often do if you a
simple method for computing a histogram
with the Laplace noise then you realize
that there are negative values and you
do some kind of normalized rounding and
as soon as you do that even simple type
of post-processing you get noise
distributions that are a little bit
skewed okay so you see some bias you see
some unequal variance happening here
okay another class of mechanisms that's
practically important are data
adaptive mechanisms these mechanisms are
actually exploiting properties of the
input data typically to lower variance
but they create bias okay so the dawa
algorithm this is one of one of our
algorithms does a kind of like data
reduction step where it privately looks
for adjacent sets of bins that could be
approximated better by just taking a
kind of total count and then assuming
uniformity because you kind of don't
have enough signal to distinguish these
bins anyway and you might as well take a
count and assume uniformity so what's
shown here is like grouping the this
histogram into into groups and then this
noisy estimate is uniform in all the in
all these regions that creates a kind of
bias but it actually can lower a squared
error lower variance a lot the multiplet
of weights mechanism starts with a
uniform estimate and iteratively
improves
by selecting the least well approximated
query privately and then measuring it
with Laplace noise and doing
multiplicative weights inference okay so
if we go back to look at the results and
we see this is sort of like Laplace
noise nicely regular this is the dawa
algorithm this is my M okay I'll show
you again the original distribution so
we see now now the sort of the question
for the algorithm designers is can we
explain what's going on here because
there's big deviations you see people
with unequal variance we see this sort
of negatively biased massive you know
variation here what's also interesting
is that we've lowered the measure of
total error so dawa is delivering better
total error but creating a kind of
disparities okay so if I went back to
that plot I could plot this and say well
Laplace has like lower disparity but not
as much accuracy as dawa all right so
now I'm going to give you another
example a lot of times very frequent
cases that somebody gives us a workload
this is you know we talked about this
mechanism in the bootcamp a month ago we
optimized to find a strategy that helps
us answer the workload queries with low
error
the workload is usually input from users
that say this is the thing I want to
know about and we select a good strategy
we apply the Laplace nodes to it and we
reconstruct the answers a good strategy
is one that is low sensitivity lower
sensitivity than the workload but can
support accurate reconstruction it's got
some nice properties the answers to the
workload queries are always unbiased so
we're not creating bias here
it's got data independent expected error
rates which are handy but it will create
expected error that sort of varies
across the workload okay so I wanted to
show an example of kind of a case where
you might use such a mechanism is a kind
of geographic hierarchy where you have
counties and
States and and and the nation and you
want to count some predicates it could
be total population but it could also be
the number of you know needy students in
in counties and you want numbers for
each county for each state and for the
nation okay so the the matrix mechanism
can optimize this workload in and what
it'll try to do is find a set of
measurements from which all of those
workload queries can be estimated and
the total error will be will be
minimized so we could we don't always I
think it's not always necessarily the
case that we expect all workload queries
to have the same expected error but we
might look at the the sort of states and
ask well would the populate what these
counts coming out of at least this state
level have roughly equivalent error and
what we find here here I've gone right
to the sort of chart of accuracy
disparity versus total accuracy and
these are different sort of solutions
different strategies that could be used
to answer the geographic hierarchy we
find that HTML our implementation of
makes and mechas mechanism will improve
on will find the the most accurate
solution but but creates some disparity
compared with for example other
solutions that answer the workload
queries themselves and then do inference
I can talk more about the details of
this but you get sort of like
populations across states that are quite
skewed and somewhat arbitrary I think
this is Virginia and and I'm not exactly
sure why but but you know we're using an
optimizer there's a part of the
challenge here is that there's a lot of
skew if you didn't catch it in the
number of counties per state some some
states have three counties and some have
250 and what the matrix mechanism is
doing is an inference process where it
it uses the noisy counts at the county
level to improve the the state
population counts and the national so
you start to see these artifacts
yeah so here the disparity measure was
sort of like the the minimum expected
the maximum expected error minus the
minimum normalized by the average no I
don't think so we're we're trying you
know we've considered a few in in the
write-up on this we have a few a few
measures and in the case in the case
studies we'll see other ones yeah but
I'm not sure you know what exactly the
right measure is first like I said
there's different social welfare
functions yeah that you use you have to
you have to say do you want the
performance to be good on average you
want the performance to pull the bottom
of the distribution
you don't specify the objective of
course what I was asking is what if
there are agreed-upon measures that you
know we could shoot for one we design
algorithms for this stuff the seats in
the House of Representative they argued
about it for two centuries and then just
wrote the formula in this
because because the Constitution was
consistently interpreted as requiring
first pass to get majority voting and so
they hand out the seats I can't switch
it over to proportional representation
or pure voting or rent voting so I don't
think there's easy answer to that
question the statutes the clearest
statutes right all of the rules don't
have then they just designate who gets
to make the decision and they prohibit
judicial review of it
so that basically chips in stone but
this is the way it's gonna work as we
saw in an earlier talk I mean did some
things it may be getting the count right
matters but in other things all that
matters is the rank you could get you
know your council maybe half what they
should be in some and twice what they
are in others but if you get the rank
right and people are applying all their
resources to whoever's at the bottom
then most of the ones in the federal
government that I know that we kick that
we do statistics on the Census Bureau if
you've got a proportion of the
population so it's yeah it's so
dependent on how it's being used yeah so
it may be problem specific but that
creates its own challenges for a
scenario where we're publishing a
reference set of statistics and
expecting everybody to use it for Alec
of these assignment problems
dislike me no intersection are given and
make the allocation there are different
kinds of measures that people try to
optimize for and so they all use
slightly different okay let me try to go
on so let's let's know I appreciate the
questions and this has been great
discussion so let's go let's even let's
go back to a scenario where we just use
Laplace noise so we don't have any
disparities and and we don't have any
bias we don't have any disparities in
error rates but we are gonna do
something with this data which is test
whose above a threshold okay so we want
to isolate the assignment populations
that are above 25 and if we do that with
Laplace noise we we already see a lot of
disparities right and this basically
Maps exactly to how close to the
decision boundary it is the true data
those people are much more susceptible
to this even the same amount of noise
now we could even consider a scenario
which again gave better total error but
creates greater disparities and again we
see you know that there's a little
there's there's this accuracy disparity
trade-off okay so now I'm gonna go on to
the case studies and I I mean the same
effects are gonna appear but I guess the
advantage of this is that these are real
problems on somewhat real data and we
can ask the the further question which
is like well at the epsilon that I care
about are these effects really going to
matter so the first problem that we're
gonna talk about is the minority
language voting benefits so this is part
of the 1965 Voting Rights Act at section
203 it states specific conditions under
which a jurisdiction which is like a
small voting district will be covered
for a specific language one of 68
languages I think considered you know
separately and each jurisdiction can be
covered or not covered
and if they are determined to be covered
by the Census Bureau they have to
publish all the materials in the in the
minority language these determinations
are made every five years and the data
is made public and so for example it's a
fairly rare classification so you know
there's 8,000 jurisdictions and in 2016
263 of those jurisdictions were covered
for some language at least one leg you
know at least one language but you know
it it ends up being a significant
fraction of the population that's
potentially affected and of course it's
a it's an important benefit because if
people don't receive this benefit when
they should they're they're
disenfranchised so here's the formula
for each just jurisdiction and for each
language
you've got to compute a set of
statistics about the jurisdiction and
they have to do with voting-age citizens
in the jurisdiction that speak a given
language l and then you've got to figure
out the fraction of those that are
limited English Proficient and then
you've got to compute the fraction of
those that are it's like an illiteracy
condition that have less than a fifth
grade education you take those
statistics you you know divide two of
them this is basically a threshold on
the limited English Proficient it's
either like an absolute threshold you
that can you can satisfy it by or a kind
of multiplicative threshold or ratio of
the of your population that's voting-age
citizens and then you also have to
satisfy this little threshold this is a
constant that they decide which has to
do with the overall u.s. illiteracy rate
and that natural illiteracy rate okay so
then if you satisfy this little boolean
condition then you're covered all right
so it's a boolean that you're either
covered or you're not covered each
jurisdiction each language okay so
here's what we did we took the public
use data okay and treated it as ground
truth all right it's not ground truth
it's got actually a lot of disclosure
limitations stuff in it and who knows
what they do to it other than John
one language which is which is Hispanic
which I know is not really language but
to the Census Bureau that's a that's a
language category and it's actually one
of the one of the most frequent ones so
in Scent in that sense that the counts
are higher and the true positives here's
our one hundred and seventy five
positively classified jurisdictions in
that in the data that we we consider a
ground truth and here's what you find if
you look at this is so then what we
measured was correct classification rate
for the covered jurisdictions alright so
those are the true positives we just
looked at of that set of 175 how often
are they going to be correctly
classified as covered as they deserve to
be all right so the you know here's the
good news the good news is that there's
some that and even a lot at epsilon 10 a
lot of them are correctly classified all
the time but the problem is that as you
as epsilon goes down you see that there
are quite a few that have very low class
correct classification rates you know so
it epsilon time we might be happy that
you know the lowest correct
classification it's 95 percent but at
lower epsilon we would probably be
unhappy now you can run this experiment
again comparing two mechanisms where one
gives lower total error actually dhawan
laplace on this on this task give about
the same total error at epsilon point
one and dawa starts to outperform
laplace at even lower Epsilon and this
graph is showing that the disparities
you know you get lower overall error but
again you get disparities that are much
more severe in fact you see people who
are I think due to the by just the bias
and the counts that dawa is creating
never going to be classified correctly
for any run of the algorithm okay yeah
instead of ranked populations what
it's ranked on population right nowit
this is this is actually just ranked on
the correct classification rate so we
had 175 drew jurisdictions yeah very
positively correlated with the
population in the voting district in the
smaller population voting districts we
published the sampling error for the for
the statistic that the determine
statistics and the determination was
made on they have a similar property but
it's not challengeable so so you guys so
I'm not worried about you doing this but
you ought to do that simulation to so I
understand you're saying you said we
should consider how many people are
disenfranchised not just like these
districts might be small a small disc
very small populations what you look at
sampling error it's gonna exhibit a
similar feature that the small districts
are districts with small populations
that the cover type they're gonna have
you know if you were to hypothetically
resample you would sort of very often
make different decisions yeah okay so
and what do you what and what do you
draw from that I mean it would be
interesting to see what to epsilon since
it's between just from the sampling okay
so you would want to compare you wanna
okay let me let me just rephrase you
want to compare this rate of missed
classification to what what is sort of
inherent in the data from sampling for
example yeah
question that head says - name we use a
phrase correctly classified some like
cleric that's what has they deserve to
be yeah right okay
[Music]
important to the policy goal that in
matters of it's ten thousand and nine
thousand or yeah and I wonder if to say
something you know else to look at and
measure that maybe kind of gets at for
example the number of speakers of that
language that don't you know that do or
don't get a ballot in there yeah well I
think that's yeah that's a totally
that's a totally valid point I mean we
asked ourselves also like why this why
does this formula exist and what does it
really mean what is it trying to capture
I don't know I didn't never got a good
answer to that but between guaranteeing
that there were these Spanish ballots
and and allowing for the possibility
that that would be balanced in one of
approximately fifty native languages
that have diminishing ly small numbers
of speakers but which might constitute
the majority or the over the threshold
in these specialized voting districts
okay I don't know if that helps the
wheel but I mean obviously I mean the
other issue is that mistakes mistakes in
in one direction seem much more costly
than than others and so we probably
shouldn't be doing this raw application
of the formula to noisy data but as I
said there's I think there's it's not so
easy to move to another another approach
direct estimates those which is one of
the simulations you should do I predict
that you will get a picture that's worse
than your red line
because so many of them are noisy based
on sampling the modeling was designed to
pool the data from large numbers of
similar districts so you can get a
better estimate where you want to pick
the line but it still can't get rid of
the variability let's do a sample yeah
okay yeah yeah you're gonna get a flip
of this I guess I mean you must have a
bunch of districts that are small that
get kind of incorrectly classified in
the other direction
yeah for sure those are probably far
more but presumably the cost they're
treated with aren't because of the
sampling variability yeah yeah yeah okay
well okay let me let me try to go I'm
almost done and I'm almost out of time
but we also studied a funding allocation
problem called title one where we you
know there's a total allocation for
school funds they're allocated to school
districts in proportion to the
essentially the number of eligible
students in the district moderated
slightly by the average student
expenditure in that district just
because things are more expensive in
some areas than others and so they they
adjust for that we treated this as true
because there's a lot of public
information about average student per
student expenditure and so here the
effects I think are a little a little
less dramatic but still you see that
because of rounding small districts tend
to get a positive bias and get over
allocated and that it's compensated for
by the larger districts so what we're
plotting here is a sort of
multiplicative error the this is the
side that the magnitude of the true
allocation and the on a log scale them
the multiplicative you know the ratio of
the of the error okay so this the one
interpretation of this is that the large
districts tend to get a you know a small
tax in order to
to compensate for the positive bias on
the small districts okay so I'll just
wrap up and hope and we can continue the
discussion I think it's the case I think
I've shown I mean that assignee
population do not bear the utility cost
of our privates are common privacy
mechanisms equally and that there's a
somewhat complicated variety of causes
for this you know including the things
I've talked about when I say those who
get asked about less often what I mean
is that when we do the workload
optimization it's the sort of queries
that don't appear so so often in your
workload or the parts of the domain that
people don't ask about so much that the
optimization can tolerate like letting
the noise go up and so you know there's
other examples I gave this state
hierarchy but you could look at like
when we optimize the SF one person's
queries and you look at the distribution
of error across age groups you find some
weird effects where very old people have
very high error and vote and there's a
they're like a step down when you look
at children versus like voting age and
there's some other other weird effects
and we could adjust you know we can
adjust for those effects and that's sort
of part of the point I guess as next
step so I'll say for what Epsilon's are
these disparities small enough to ignore
and then I guess the big question that
or the big response that's emerged here
is that you know these effects exist in
the data because of sampling and
therefore we should see how the the
magnitude of the effects how they
compared to those may be also I mean I
also think it's interesting you know the
extent to which they I mean does that
mean they could compensate for each
other or it's not as bad or we shouldn't
blame the privacy mechanism I'm not sure
what the what the conclusion is I think
we can change our privacy mechanisms to
address some of these for example I mean
a very concrete thing for us to
implement in the context of the matrix
mechanism is another optimization
objective that risks you know that
targets just accuracy disparities and I
think we can do that and we're
at that it's obviously interesting to
look at post-processing or more
sophisticated assignment methods that
take into account the noise if you can
if you can analyze the noise but there's
questions about whether this is you know
palatable from the standpoint of
regulation and then I would you know
perhaps ask you know if you were a
resident of some of these jurisdictions
and you were going to be disadvantaged
by you know by the privacy mechanism or
at least in part because of the privacy
mechanism would you still choose to be
to have your privacy protected at the
same level or might you want to choose
if you were able to to have less privacy
and more more accuracy more money
overall okay and with this and you know
thank my collaborators and all the
simulations were run in in our system
ekta low so students if your advisers
want to reproduce these results point
them there
[Applause]